Hắn thẳng bên dưới dựa thế lan và cà bu chiếm bức săng ngày thứ ba với nhiều dễ biến nghiệm trong.
Để ữ phó, cà bu chiếm bởi dộ vùng cấm bay tới ba tình và hạn chế độ cao hỏa đậu hành không,
nhằm chẳng Wi cơ suy zor từ giao chanh.
Cũng lúc, hơn năm 2018 hậu ở năm 2019, bên dưới phải tạm ngừng hỏa đậu.
Anh hưởng cưới khoảng 1 chăm bao miền học sinh và giá viên.
Thái lan, cộng bán hành lệnh đống cửa gần cám chân học ở các khu vực nguy cơ cao,
đồng thời trên khai sơ tán khẩn có phó vinh tại các tình giáp ca bu chiếm.
Một số trường được chuyển đội thành lơ chú ảnh tạm thời trong ở dân thiện hưởng.
Ý tính tổng cộng hơn một chăm bày mấy miền người ở các hai bên biệt dưới đã phải sơ tán.
Cho khi giao chanh chưa có giấu hiệu hạn yệt, các biển pháp phòng vệ dân sự cho thành yêu thiên hàng đầu,
cho thấy mức độ căn thẳng và hệ quả lan dọt của cuộc suốt này,
đối với Anh Linh khu vực và đời sống dân cơ.